this is the coffee you give your stepdad
you know he tells you to go get a coffee
and you put 15 packs of splendid and
like here you go you dick
today we're gonna be trying custom
starbucks drinks i love starbucks
i had a mini addiction to it in college
you know i think when people usually
customize their drinks i assume they're
trying to be healthier
like oh can we have like non-fat milk or
no sugars as someone who really likes
starbucks i'm intrigued to see
what starbucks beverages i'm not going
to enjoy and if there are starbucks
beverages that i'm going to be like
not today's satan let's do it
i don't like that there's a lid on this
because i don't have full eye
recognition of what's gonna be in it
smells like some kind of spice this
smells like a trash fire
i'm gonna say something that i can't
believe i'm saying
but that's not terrible
what starts out pumpkin spice which is
fine and then it goes into this really
bitter
like burnt coffee mixed with medicine
it's like you bit into a rotten
pomegranate yeah exactly
[Music]
the 20 shots of pumpkin spice syrup
made me like i don't play with demons
okay i don't [ __ ] around
that's disgusting that's way too sugary
sweet but
because there are 14 shots in there this
tastes like
diesel fuel which is exactly how i like
my coffee
[Music]
what's great about this is it used to be
iced it's cold
it's a melted frappuccino by now let's
take this one okay
oh that's sweet that tastes like a
melted hershey bar
oh okay this is another one that started
off okay
but there's so much artificial sweetener
or something in here that my tongue is
like sticking to the roof of my mouth
[Music]
i want to know what type of person
wants 12 packets of sugar and there's
starbucks
i feel like this person watches the
person make the coffee as well it's like
i need to make sure those are 12 packs
right they're like
aha yeah this has to be some like soccer
mom
it just like needs the adrenaline glass
i want to know what their health record
is like because this is diabetes
in a drink
it's a frappuccino yeah it looks like
those drinks the kids are always
drinking at the mall
you go to the mall there's like
five-year-olds drinking ventis it's
ridiculous yeah
where are these kids patients all right
cheers let's go for it
[Music]
oh this is so good i don't think so
this is my favorite there's so much
sugar in this
that it just like i feel like it just
slid down my throat
oh no oh my god
it tastes like pure caramel
just because there is almond milk in
your drink does not mean it's healthy
800 grams of sugar but my god i'm gonna
put almond milk in there
you know everyone has a different taste
and i respect that but i think
once you go over like 10 packets of
something anything
it's a little too much if you're
ordering one of these drinks
the only thing i have to say to you is
you need to talk to a medical
professional
because something is wrong
and or something will go wrong in the
very near future
[Music]